simal à attraper
une rencontre épisodique être [ __ ] à l'
ère des Avengers d'Ultron les Avengers doivent faire face
au problème de l'entité mondiale c'est
un terrain de jeu différent, nous
traitons ces situations à un
niveau mondial autant que possible c'est
un  film beaucoup plus grand que le premier
Avengers juste visuellement où nous allons
nous sommes en Italie il fait incroyablement froid et
pluvieux
nous l'aimons La maison de New York à la
Avengers Tower qui est un énorme
fan très enthousiaste ils sont très accueillants
nous laissant prendre en charge leur  rues pendant
quelques jours
aujourd'hui, les Avengers se retrouvent au
château de Douvres poursuivant le tour du monde
veulent regarder les Avengers voir l'
effet qu'ils ont sur le monde entier pour
qu'ils viennent dans des endroits comme le
bourg de Chehalis et emportent avec eux les
ennuis inévitables qui suivent  eux, comment cela affecte-t-il
leur perception les uns des autres
et la perception du monde selon laquelle nous
demandons vraiment que la lune ne fasse jamais un
spectacle complet, nous avons beaucoup plus d'
endroits que nous avons  e jamais auparavant et en
quelque sorte couvert plus de terrain et donc
esthétiquement tout vient d'être
composé Avengers merde récit
Eternia
vous